e
e e
I
second
sure good afternoon for the record my
name is Gary Merchant I'm the chair of
the study committee for sb560 which is a
committee that studied the impact of
Pharmacy benefit manager on operations
the cost Administration distribution of
prescription
drugs and to my left is Senator
just turn your mic on don't
forget oh he's you would like me to
introduce myself okay thank you thank
you Mr chair I'm Shannon chandley um I
serve uh District 11 in the state
senate thank you to my right uh
representative Brian Cole Mr Hillsboro
26 uh Carrie spear nationville award
three uh Commerce Committee thank you
and for those who come to speak before
the committee I'd ask you to come to the
table and use the mic so we can hear
what you're saying clearly and
distinctly at the same time
representative Cole has a device to
capture what we're saying and I think
transcribe everything so as the clerk he
found the technology to do the job I
commend him for that so thank you there
you
go so the agenda today is pretty
straightforward there's basically two
things on the agenda one is to hear from
the insurance department is
what oversight if you will what
Authority they have over the PBM
industry itself and basically asked um
Michelle Heaton to come forward I think
you have a presentation to give to us as
well and the second part of the meeting
will be talking about maximum allowable
cost and try to understand the
terminology how it works in the
marketplace I've asked um pharmacist
Clifford to be here talk about this from
the State Medicaid Program because they
also have ma price how it works and for
us to begin to understand uh the nuances
to it so miss e if you want to take this
away
please good afternoon my name is
Michelle he and I'm the director of life
and health with the New Hampshire
insurance department I've put together a
presentation that I think you guys all
have print outs of since we don't
actually have a presenting capabilities
here but it kind of goes over the um
Insurance Department's regulatory
Authority and explains how the
difference between tpas pbms and how
Managed Care works so if you join me on
um the second
page uh New Hampshire laws relating to
prescription drug oversight this is a
list of some of the chapters and
administrative rules and administrative
bulletins that all relate to either the
regulation of um Pharmacy benefit
managers pbms third party administrators
or um prescription drugs so there are a
number of different provisions and it
gets complicated when you're trying to
figure out what we're talking about so
that's where I'm going to start walking
you through what some of this stuff
means so if you go to the next page um
number three what is a TPA a TPA is a
third-party administrator and those are
entities that provide administrative
support to an insurance company or
health plan pursuant to a contract so an
insurance company is the company that
designs the plan files it with the
insurance department we review it and
ensure that it complies with law
and then we would approve it to be sold
the TPA is a separate entity that the
insurer will contract with to do certain
functions so sometimes that's assisting
with claims Administration that can be
um helping out with a subset of benefits
so sometimes it can be Pharmacy benefits
sometimes it can be mental health
benefits and they can do a variety of
different things the contract that that
third- party entity has with the help
carrier is going to delineate what the
responsibilities are what the oversight
is we have a law which is RSA 402h that
regulates thirdparty administrators
thirdparty administrators must be
licensed and receive a certificate of
authority from the
department and there are certain
Financial requirements they have to file
annual reports they have to be solvent
but at the end of the day if they're
helping administer claims it's not their
money that they're using to administer
those claims it's the insurers money and
the TPA is just the entity that's
helping assist that but they don't take
on any of that risk associated with the
insurance
product
um there are additionally in 402h
certain parameters of what tpas can do
and how that stuff works but we're not
get into too much of that uh the next
page number four is what is a PBM so PBM
or Pharmacy benefit manager is just a
subset of a type of a PB of a TPA so
they are thirdparty administrators
except that a PBM only is in the area of
prescription
drugs so there's a separate statute that
regulates Pharmacy benefit managers and
that's RSA
402n and like tpas they have to be
registered with our department we
monitor Financial solvency and there's
also data reporting requirements that
they have to submit to
us however for both tpas
and pbms there's exceptions so generally
speaking the way we have defined PBM in
this statute under 402n is it's a person
business or other entity that pursuant
to a contract with a health carrier
manages the prescription drug coverage
for the health carrier or provided by
the health carrier so they're only
dealing with that one as aspect of the
insurance contract they do not include
Health Care Facilities Health Care
Professionals licensed in the state
Consultants working um either with a
pharmacy benefit manager or a Carrier
Services provided by CMS or Medicare or
Medicaid services and it does not
include a health insurer so a health
insurer sometimes can have its own PBM
that is fully owned by the insurer but
it's maybe a technically a separate
legal
entity to the extent that PBM is working
for the insurer they are do not qualify
within our definition as a PBM and would
not be subject to this registration
requirement attorney heon do you want us
to ask questions along your journey or
do you want us to wait until the end no
feel free to jump in okay so I want to
follow up on that comment about the PBM
that's owned by the insurance company so
at that point in time they're not
licensed by the state because if I
understand it correctly the insurance
company that owns them is the one that's
licensed yes so therefore if that's the
case how does the insurance department
regulate the pvm they're not necessarily
regulating that separate entity they're
and we'll get to this so let me go ahead
a few and then I'll come back to that
okay um so going to the next slide
whether something qualifies as a TPA
under our statute you you have to figure
out what specific Activities The Entity
is
doing who is the entity Contracting with
and whether the entity is fully owned by
insurer those are the three factors and
even if they qualify as a TPA if they're
doing or I mean if they qualify as a PBM
if they're doing any activities that
could require them to be licensed as a
TPA or utilization review entity they
would also need to have those licenses
as well and that's where it starts
getting very complicated and that's why
you have to look at what what activities
are they doing who are they Contracting
with and who owns them to figure out
whether they need to register or not so
if you go to the next slide number six
that has the chart this kind of walks
you through a lot of those different
scenarios so um also in the PBM
statute it um you have to have a
contract with a health carrier and
health carrier is defined um Within
you're selling commercial insurance so
if you are a self-funded plan you are
not a health carrier so if there is an
entity providing PBM like
services to that self-funded plan that's
falling outside of the definition of PBM
in our statute however you do fall
within the definition of a TPA so you
would be regulated as a TPA and a lot of
the regulations for TB TPA and PBM are
very similar the only big distinction is
that pbms have more of that data
reporting requirement that tpas don't
necessarily have and there's various
reasons for that if I so did that help
it did I want to go back if I may to the
previous
page and my concern is that if I heard
it correctly if the
insurance
entity owns the
PBM you're not regulating the PBM
because it's owned by the insurance my
concern is if I understand the
market Etna owns CVS Mna owns Express
Scripts United Healthcare owns Optima so
therefore 80% of the market is not being
overseen by the insurance department
it's you're seeing the insurance carrier
but not the PBM under
it there's caveats to that so if
there're to the extent that PBM is doing
Services solely for the insurance
company they fall into that exception if
that PBM contracts with other insurance
carriers that they are not owned by or
self-funded entities then they can start
falling outside of those exceptions and
they would need to either um register as
a TPA or PBM or possibly both depending
on who they're Contracting
with so the question I would go back to
is
that are we talking about oright for the
part that's outside of their ownership
in other words if I'm
Edna and I'm looking at
CVS but CVS has other agreements with
other organizations if you go sell the
plans and so forth are you overseeing
all of CVS or only the part that is
outside of the parameters of Ed I think
too we have to think about what are we
trying to oversee here so we're
regulating The Entity or are we
regulating the underlying plan so that's
the next part the presentation so when
we're talking about these license
requirements if you fall within you know
these definitions and you have to
register that means that entity as a
whole needs to register their financials
that we're looking at are for the entire
entity when we're re um reviewing
qualifications for the people on the
board for initial license or stuff like
that we're looking at the entire entity
so in that respect if you fall into any
of these definition that would require
you to register then the entire entity
is registered whether only a portion of
your um business would fall into Managed
Care laws and the other portions of your
business fall without so when we're
talking about regulating pbms and
prescription drugs we're really talking
about two different things are we
talking about the entity PBM its
financials and who owns it or are we
talking about the prescription drugs and
how they're being administered pursuant
to insurance contracts which are kind of
two different issues I think what I'm
looking for
excuse me is what I call
consistency so that all players are
treated equally and we don't have
caveats and car outs for this versus
that and so forth my concern is that the
insurance department doesn't sound like
it has a broad regulatory authority over
the whole pvm part of it depending upon
what class they're in what caveats they
have and that's my concern is that I
keep hearing the word registered but
still trying to figure out what is the
regulatory oversight that you actually
have to be sure that what they're
supposed to be delivering is being
delivered number two if I have a
complaint where does that complaint go
because that was the other question we
hopefully get through it here is how
many complaints does the insurance
department receive on an annual basis
from pharmacies patients providers those
are things I'm trying to understand
because if there's no place for those
complaints to land and the place they
land doesn't have any regulatory
oversight accountability and hold them
accountable outside of the fact they
have registration I'm not sure exactly
what kind oversight we actually have so
when we're talking about regulating The
Entity as a whole they are registered
with us we review financials to ensure
solvency we ensure that their board is
made up of appropriate people um those
initial things to get licensed and then
renewals after that monitoring Financial
SOL SOL sorry Financial solvency
um that is their ability to operate as a
PBM in this state what they're doing as
a PBM then is pursuant to their
contracts so that was one of the things
to be a PBM you have to have a contract
you know with a carrier or a Health Plan
um and what they're doing as a part of
their activities falls into what's in
that cont contract if we're talking
about Commercial Insurance we have the
ability to
regulate how they're administering that
product but the person or the entity
that's ultimately responsible for how
that product is AD being administered is
the carrier not the PBM the PBM is just
doing what is in their contract with the
carrier so does the PBM have any fiary
responsibility back to the insurance
company or does it have any
responsibility for them fin
outside of saying well they have a
contract with the insurance and the
insurance care is the one holding the
produci responsibilities or do we
actually have the ability for the PBM to
be held accountable because at the end
of the day they're the ones that I
understand it correctly are handling all
the money and I get nervous when people
handle all the money and there's no
responsibility for the person handling
the money so the carriers are
responsible for overseeing any third-
party administrator or PBM working with
them those entities do not assume any
insurance risk the carrier is
responsible for paying those claims and
is ultimately responsible for that in
the contract is how the third party
entity or PBM is going to be reimbursed
and there's different models for how
that reimbursement is going to work but
the money is basically passed from the
insurer to the PBM PBM pay the claims
when they're doing claims in
administration if we monitor those
entities for financial solvy because if
there's problems with solvy we want to
make sure that gets addressed before
there's claims going unpaid and you know
money missing we don't want that to
happen um but at the end of the day if
something like that were to happen the
carrier is still ultimately responsible
for pay ensuring those claims get paid
whether they're using a third party
administrator a PBM or some other um
entity they' have to be a TPA because
you'd have to be licensed here but
they're the ones that assume the risk
and they're only administer uring the
benefits pursuant to their contract with
the carrier and usually that relates to
how um the benefits are laid out in the
insurance
policy thank you for that explanation
but I'll turn it over to my colleagues
on the committee as well do you have any
questions well my concern is that which
is still don't clearly understand is
who's regulating the PM and the fiary
respon responsibility because at the end
of the day it's a question at that point
in time is that if they're the ones
controlling Pur strings if they're the
ones that are basically making the um
working on behalf of the insurance
industry you think there'd be some
accountability back to the insurance
outside of a
contract
in in the case where we have things like
Etna owning CVS
that gets a little more
complicated but in general what I've
seen based on all the things we've
hashed over back at the uh Commerce
Committee is that the fiduciary
responsibility in the end is the
insurance
company for the most part now this CVS
slash eus situation or one of the other
two that one I still have questions on
because there vertically integrated
throughout the whole thing and I think
maybe if we concentrate on that area we
might get a better handle on what's
happening there because that's not the
typical situation like we have with the
other ones so could you go over that
once again all right let's let's just
use a real a real example if I have I
have a a Harvard Pilgrim and I need a
drug so I go to the
drugstore
uh and I get a card I have a drug
card and I get it paid for I mean I get
you know whatever whatever rate they pay
me for so there's a PBM and that's CVS
in this particular
case who
is now remember my insurance carrier is
Harvard Pilgrim it's not
Etna in that case is CVS as a
PBM has to make all of their financials
and fiduciary
responsibility I'm not clear on how that
affects I mean we I'm not etus so I'm
I'm Harvard Pilgrim oh they have a
contract with Harvard Pilgrim and so
Harvard Pilgrim is responsible for the
fiduciary responsibility for how CVS
behaves as a PBM for Harvard Pilgrim is
that correct yeah I I mean I'm hesitant
we're talking fiduciary duty because I
I'm not sure who who we're talking about
duties with respect to but Harvard has
essentially then in your scenario sold a
product that is um representing it's
going to cover certain prescription
benefits it has then contracted with CVS
to help them administer those benefits
at the end of the day if CVS does
something outside of its contract with
Harvard then it's those parties need to
resolve that contractual dispute so in
effect that's the same as it would be
for any PBM SL insurance company as they
behave but now the
regulations is all of CVS acting as a
PBM regardless of who the insurance
carrier is which set of laws do they
have to obey with respect to the state
and I got the impression they would have
to all of it would have to be under your
purview so that's where it gets tricky
because when we're talking about well
which state of which laws if you're in a
commercial insurance product then they
have to comply with all of the insurance
laws applicable to that insurance
product regardless of whether it's a PBM
or a health insurer administering the
benefits when we're talking about
regulating the PBM the PBM is not
selling the insurance product they're
just administering it so technically
pbms are just complying with the
registration you know those typical
standard things because they're not
creating the the insurance product and
they're not responsible for marketing or
selling it and they don't hold the
insurance risk associated with it so if
if we keep going the presentation I
think some of these things will come a
little bit clear um so after the chart
that goes through kind of the various
how you would be registered we get into
um on page
seven um the fact that there could be
multiple things you have to register for
if you're doing any kind of utilization
review you have to be registered at a as
a utilization review entity unless
you're ured doing your own utilization
review inh house
um all of these entities are subject
except are no all of them are subject to
examination and audit and investigations
by the insurance com department so if we
think one of these entities is doing
something that's illegal we can go in
and investigate and examine that so
that's where we have we do have the
regular authority over these entities um
and as I mentioned before tpas and pbms
do have um any ual financial reporting
requirements now the difference here is
we're talking about entities there
health insurance is the regulated
product and health carriers are the ones
that develop those products and sell
them
um and they're the ones assuming the
risk so the way we regulate those
products is the health insurer comes up
with the product they file it with our
department we review the entire policy
and product and ensure that it complies
with all state and federal laws then we
would approve it once it's approved they
can sell it to Consumers once it's in
the market and consumers have it we also
are monitoring how that plane is being
administered to ensure that not only on
paper did it comply with our laws but in
practice is the policy working in
accordance with all of our laws so
that's our Market conduct aspect to the
extent we get any kind of consumer
complaints or inquiries we would open
investigations look into that and make
sure um you know the plan is operating
the way it's supposed to so on the next
slide um slide
eight kind of goes into kind some of the
stuff that we
do we have to review everything before
it's sold once it's sold we we continue
to monitor it we're also looking at the
premium rates and that's where you know
the actuaries come in and make sure is
the rate they're charging actuar sound
we want to make sure that the company is
not going over by um putting premium too
low we also need to make sure that
premium is not excessive so that's also
goes into part of the review in the
department we also are reviewing the
financials of insurance companies so
they have annual filings and they have
quarterly filings and we were monitoring
that on a constant basis to make sure
that these insurance companies are
solvent so that their money is there
when the claims come
in so moving on to the next one so when
we're talking about well what laws are
there with respect to prescription drug
benefits there's lot a and depending on
what Market you're in depends on which
rules and laws apply so there's large
group small group individual and then
within the individual and small group
you have on Exchange and off exchange on
Exchange is what's sold on the federal
Insurance Exchange those are qhp or
qualified health plans and they have
heightened requirements that not all
plans meet so those are kind of like the
the strictest requirements there and
they do have stuff that is specific to
prescription drug and reviewing
formularies now where we do not have
jurisdiction is when there are
self-funded plans government plans
Medicare Medicaid Tri care so to the
extent a PBM is operating in one of
those markets for the most part as a
state there is no regulatory Authority
we cannot regulate something that the
federal government is already regulating
and then with Arisa we're preempted from
doing a lot of regulation in that space
as well that's where we don't have
necessarily Authority it's not over the
entity we have authority over the entity
it's the activities they're doing that
fall outside our jurisdiction is where
we don't have the
authority so if you go to um number
10 this is where we start getting to
manage care so in New Hampshire health
and pretty much in the country health
insurance operates on a Managed Care
model so the idea is that this is your
HMO po plans you are in a plan and the
health carrier is negotiating with
providers
um all kinds of healthcare providers
hospitals facilities drug companies
medical device manufacturers to get the
best rate they can for their covered
people and that's how they help mitigate
costs if they can negotiate better rates
then you're getting that discount by
buying their product that's how the keep
cost Dam that's how the model works so
um outside of prescription drugs you
know you have to go to in network
providers those are providers that the
insurer has negotiated a contract with
they have come up with a contractual
rate for their services and that is how
they're controlling cost pbms and
prescription drugs are doing the exact
same thing they're entering into
contracts to negotiate a better rate for
the people in those insurance plans at
the most basic level that that is mag
care and that's what they're doing so in
doing that you are steering your covered
people into certain places is because at
the end of the day you're responsible
for paying all those claims and you want
to make sure you're making the most cost
efficient options that are also quality
so that's why we have laws surrounding
that to make sure that it's not just the
cheapest option that you know people do
have access to medically necessary care
and that certain things are going to be
included in that attorney Eden please
yes um you brought up the word steering
which is
interesting so so if
I'm CVS or camart again
follow Spears um comment about being
vertically
integrated what's to
prevent the insurance which owns the pvm
which owns the pharmacy from steering
things internally to their own benefit
and not allowing the patient greater
access freom of choice
that is in some respects the whole
purpose of Managed Care is to steer
patients to lower cost options so
there's nothing necessarily that
prevents them from doing that and that's
what you would see with traditional hmos
all the time it's you know a hospital
HMO that is requiring all their covered
persons to go within their hospital
system to manage costs so in that
respect it's very similar but in New
Hampshire we do not have laws that
prevent that from happening
understanding that we don't have laws in
that specific
area
uh and
and as representative Merchant has
indicated this vertical integration of
CVS and Etna if I would have belonged to
Etna and I got steered of course to
CVS right down the chain and in some
cases these days to their drug right
because I think make a generic for
Humera
uh if let's say that drug was not it is
pretty cheap I mean cheaper than Huma
but let's say it wasn't and then in the
future it may not be would we have any
visibility that they were steering us to
drugs that were more
expensive would we have any visibility
whether we have control
consumers somewhat because there are
transparency laws that you could find
that out so there are that's the whole
push behind transparency we have
transparency laws here there's Federal
transparency laws that require
disclosure of certain things um as
Regulators we would be able to look into
that type of thing so those laws do
exist for transparency yes would you be
so kind as to send those laws to the
committee so we can review those laws
yeah so um we're jumping ahead but our
second to last slide um these are two of
the transparency initiatives in New
Hampshire that we have data currently
posted we're working on getting more but
it's a process some of the transparency
and coverage um laws are just becoming
effective and it's a matter of getting
all that data together cleaning it up
making it in Ausable so we're in the
process of doing that but these two
sites um the prescription drug cost and
utilization in New Hampshire is on New
Hampshire Health cost and those are I
believe are the top 50 drugs prescribed
and you can see um utilization and price
there we're working on putting more of
it together but can get you the specific
citations to transparency and coverage
we also have um some specific New
Hampshire laws that um Le that are
transparency purposes one of them just
got passed in our last session I believe
it was s sp555 where we expanded some of
the transparency and data rep so that's
that's coming um we were collecting data
we are now be going to be collecting
slightly more data and we're in the
process of putting out guidance to to do
that and once we have that stuff we will
be posting it you know on our website
for the public but one of the things we
found when we were talking about 555 is
that maybe the list that's in there is
not necessarily the best list did you
and I was well we fix that in
oh
yeah so it was a last we were in a
committee of conference and there's a
lot of back and forth but what it landed
on with I remember I don't remember that
the list was actually modified itself
was taken out but it was put back in so
it expanded um we got rid of some of the
stuff but we did expand what we will be
collecting as part of that okay I may
not have recognized that
so looking at New Hampshire Health cost
if I understand this a sort of a portal
and I've used actually a couple of times
myself when I've gone into the port
portal and I have a test that needs to
be done because the provider wants me to
get an MRI whatever it's going to be
blood work
it's actually very beneficial because I
can go to the portal I can look at and
say okay Hospital a is doing this
Hospital B is doing this I can actually
see the price points by each facility so
if I'm a patient now and I got a
prescription in my
hand where do I go to find out where
that price is based upon the the
pharmacy the pvm and so forth how do I
know the again
transparency is how do I know as a
patient what the prices are
right now and I'm not up to speed on all
the things there are some sites out
there that help do this we are in the
process internally at the New Hampshire
insurance department of coming up with
ways to make this information more
accessible there is transparency and
coverage Provisions that are coming into
place that will help with that um it's a
matter of implementing those um those
changes there are also um requirements
for advanced
eobs um so
so I'd have to look into that a little
bit more but there are websites and
there are projects in development that
will help consumers do that because I
think at the end of the
day and carriers can answer for
themselves but you want that's a lot of
Health Care and Health Care spending we
want people to start shopping around and
see yes this is more convenient for me
but it actually it's costing every it's
costing you know $200 more if I go a
little bit further I can go here and get
this for a lot cheaper if consumers were
more Savvy in that way we could help
bring down health care costs as a whole
if we bring down healthc care costs as
the whole premiums go down in theory I
think right now it's more making them
not go like this and more like this you
know um I don't think I don't know we'll
see I don't know that they'll go down
but we want to try to stop the Steep
increases of Health um Health Care
spending generally prescription drug is
one of those that keeps going up at a
higher rate so there's a lot of options
a lot of ideas out there about how to
best cut down on this I don't think at
this point in time anyone has found the
solution that's going to work for
everyone everyone is trying to implement
when I say everyone I'm talking about
different states are trying to implement
different laws and requirements with the
goal of trying to bring down these costs
but some of them are new and we haven't
seen how those are going to play out
some of them are a little bit older but
they have not necessarily seen those
cost savings they were looking for so
it's something that everyone is working
on and we're trying to figure out ways
of doing that but to your point I think
giving people that information is the
hope that people who become more healthc
care Savvy more consumer Savvy start
looking these things up will be able to
help you know realize the cost of these
health care services and then that could
cause them to um behave differently for
the sake of everyone easier said than
done thank you for that I'm going to
date myself here but when I started
practicing Pharmacy one of the things we
had to do was to post the top 200 um the
prices for each one of those
prescriptions again why we did that was
because the law required it and why did
the law required is bring in
transparency to the patient so the
patient going walk into the pharmacy
know what the price point was before
they actually bought the prescription
and that's what I'm trying to get to
here as a patient today I have no
clue what I'm going to be charged I
don't know where to go I don't have any
portal to go to there's no commonality
to it the price points are all over the
place I'll talk about this later in the
Mac environment I had a patient not
myself
but there was a pharmacy same
PBM same day same drug three different
prices and as a patient how do I know
I'm just I'm talking to the choir right
now but I think we need to figure out
how we can get the information out to
the public and help the patient
understand what's there yeah and that's
definitely something we're working on
there have been recent changes in
federal law and transparency and
coverage they're just you know getting
to that point of being implemented so I
think you know in a few years this stuff
will be more readily accessible it's
just it's a matter of implementing that
it now and I think I don't know for
curies they can answer for themselves
but um it I'd have to look into it more
but I think if the person called their
insurance provider they should be able
to provide them with some of that
information because the insurance
carrier knows what the prices are
everywhere because they've negotiated
those contracts
[Laughter]
so I'm again saying the same thing is as
three different patients one in the same
Pharmacy same drug same PBM and had
three different prices
so when I call in what price do I get
the one I'm supposed to get somebody's
going to get I'm saying it's very
complicated it's very convoluted but
what I keep going back to is on page
eight when you talk about regulated
industry you regulate the
product which is the insurance yes
Pharmacy benefits and insurance so how
are you regulating the pharmacy benefit
insurance so Pharmacy benefits um when
we're talking about individual and small
group they are in a such health benefit
they are part of the health insurance
plan they are not a separate coverage it
is all part of your major medical
insurance plan
however that might not be obvious to
people because sometimes that
prescription drug piece is farmed out to
a PBM so people think it's two different
entities but it's not it's all part of
your major medical coverage so it falls
into manag care law all of those laws
apply especially in the individual and
small group when we're talking about
large group it gets a little bit
trickier because we're talking about um
employer benefit plans so they do have
some more flexibility to pick and choose
different aspects and they may have a
standalone prescription drug plan that
is a little bit different but a lot of
those laws still apply to prescription
drug plans so it it depends what type of
product you're talking about but for the
most part individual small group plans
um you would have to comply with all of
the Managed Care laws and um if you're
being sold on Exchange you also have to
comply with the qhp law so if we keep
going um I'm losing where we were even
at uh number 11 page 11 is the list of
and these are the ones that are really
specific to prescription drugs um and it
I've kind of tried to um delineate which
they apply to so 420j those ones apply
to all markets that's Managed Care laws
15 RSA 156 those ones apply to
individual and 41518 ones those are
group 415 26 and 27 those apply to all
markets and then the federal law the 45
CFR there is applicable to on Exchange
those qhp
plans so when I look at on this list I
see it applies to all markets that
include self-funded no because that's
not
insurance so
so so we're just talking about the
commercial insurance that the state
regulates but the state has the
authority not so much in the plan design
but in the economics of it according to
rutage they have some saying what goes
on with the pvm side of the equation so
what are we doing on the economic side
versus the planet
side I'm not sure I'm following
question if you look at other states
like Arkansas they have actually gone
into looking at the economics and the
cost and so forth within the pvm world
and that was decided by the Supreme
Court en rollage so I understand plan
design is off the table that's un
covered through Arisa because that's
really the insurance but what are we
doing the state to help out looking at
the economics and the cost structure
within the PBM World who's overseeing
that to some extent we
are can you explain to what means we say
some extent be kind of vag within the
New Hampshire insurance department we
have a data analytics team we are also
charged with doing the annual hearing
every year where we're looking into cost
drivers so when we're doing those
projects we're looking at the cost
drivers in the health insurance Market
globally and we also you know look at
how much of the market is commercial
what's Medicare Medicaid where what are
the size of these markets what are the
um overlying also with the um the state
employee plan they opt into the chis
data so we're looking at those chis out
of Trends and health costs we are
looking at more than just the commercial
Market generally when you're talking
about what some other states did in
Rutledge rutage related to the way a PBM
can operate in
filling prescriptions I believe and I'd
have to look back and that was specific
to how a PBM operates it was not
specific to plan benefits and that's why
it was not preempted by Arisa when we're
talking about the plan benefits and the
structure of how those are provided
that's where the commercial insurance
the insurance department regulates it or
if it's aissa preemptive then it would
be the employer that um decides how
that's going to be
done if I can go back um in regards to
Arkansas it's how the PBM operates it's
not about the plan design yes so what
are we doing on the PBM operations in
the state of New Hampshire to have some
regulatory authority over the
operations I mean none of our laws they
operate pursuant to their contract so
other than that we don't necessarily
have laws I
mean to the extent that the PBM was also
a pharmacy you would have to comply with
that to the extent you're you know um a
wholesaler or something like that you
would have to apply with comply with you
know those Pharmacy laws but as an in as
a PBM entity
we don't tell them how they have to
operate other than you have to be
financially solvent and you have to you
know follow what's in your contract to
the extent they're um operating in the
space of commercial stuff then they
would have to comply with insurance laws
but that would also be part of their
contract you can't contract way you know
it's legally required so there you know
prompt pay for example is one of the
laws we have where you have to
adjudicate clean claims within a certain
number of days if they are you know
adjudicating those claims they would
have to follow that law so that's kind
of the extent of what we do for how they
operate um I'm not sure like what what
what are you thinking that we should be
regulating I guess well part of it can
be as simple
as the frequency on which a payment is
done with a pharmacy it' be something to
do at that point in time with complaints
by the pharmacy or the community or the
patients and that's all about operations
nothing plan design so at that point in
time is how they're operating I mean
when I think of this as another um sort
of a an example you have a general
contractor and they paid a bucket of
money and they subcontract it but every
single one the subcontractors also is
regulated and has meet
requirements they don't sit there and
say it's holy owned subcontractor I
don't need to worry about it if you are
subcontracting it out there is some sort
of compli some sort of vehicle that you
had to be held accountable to and it's
for the protection of the citizens that
the subcontractor is doing the work
they're supposed to do even though
legally the general contractor is going
to have some responsibility to it as
well but there's also responsibility at
the subcontractor level so I look at the
relationship between the insurance
industry and the pvm this will up a
subcontractor and I'm looking for what
kind
of regulatory Authority um what kind of
influence we have how do we look at the
operations how do we hold them
accountable and what do we hold them
accountable to so there are certain
operational requirements in our laws and
to the extent an insurer is
subcontracting or using a third party um
administrator in some fashion that
entity has to follow those laws and
insurers are required to go in and audit
those entities and have oversight of
that on an ongoing basis so it's not
something that you can just delegate out
and then have no oversight over they
need to be o overseeing all of that so
we do have that also to the respect with
respect to pbms in actual pharmacies
we're going for argument sake if we're
talking about in network pharmacies
those pharmacies also have contracts
with the insurer so there are um certain
rights within their contracts with the
insurer um as in network providers that
they can Avail themselves of and that's
with complaint complaints that's with
grievances contract negotiations um
timing of payments all that stuff is
typically going to be in that provider
contract so there are in some there are
contracts between the different entities
that are delineating a lot of these
things we do not necessarily regulate
what is in that contract for the most
part there are certain laws saying
provider contracts need to have XY and z
and as long as they have that the rest
of the details are up to the Contracting
parties to work out
so in the state of New Hampshire I
believe we have something called any
willing provider
law no we do
not yes we
do are you talking about for pharmacies
yes what I'm trying to get to if I have
an any willing provider law it says if
I'm willing to accept the contract I
should be able to take and build that
patient I don't have to say have a
contract or have the same contract with
the PBM because the reason for it being
there is they give the patient the
freedom of choice which is very
important to us so at that point in time
how is the insurance department
enforcing any willing provider well if
there's and I'm not exactly sure that
that's exactly what our law say is an
any willing provider I think there are
parameters that are similar to that but
I don't know that I would classify it
but for argument sakes if it is any
willing provider then you're agreeing to
accept the contractual rate so I mean
I'm not sure what else it still Falls
with impr prompt pay so you would have
to submit the claim and you would be
assuming it's a clean claim you would be
reimbursed within that period of time
and you would be agreeing to accept
whatever that contractual rate was going
to be
so I'm not sure where would the regul
like what more would we be regulating
we' be regulating to ensure that the
claims are paid in according in
accordance with the law uh we actually
have some people I think in the audience
that they're willing to come and speak
to us about this yeah my understanding
is that they may not always have access
to a
contract because under the Willing un
willing provide a law they should be
able to have access to it but a lot of
times they're not granted the access so
therefore they can't even Bill and take
care of their patients so I want to be
sure that they have the opportunity as a
provider to care for their patients
under that law and I want to be sure
that that law is being enforced so this
point in time as a patient I have
the right if you will to go to any
pharmacy I want
to even though it may be outside of
network I may have to pay a different
that's what I'm trying to get to is
understand the patient rights here
versus the pvm's rights does someone so
anyone else want can you speak your
friend here does someone know what law
we're talking about
here
Curtis give me a second yeah I'm not
sure if I'm understand your Mr chairman
by the way
ctis so we we do have a law that says
that um the carrier has to reimburse the
usual customary rate or um or the co-pay
whichever is less but that would I would
not say is an any willing provider and
we do have products that have in network
Pharmacy benefits and out of network and
then there's tiered networks where if
you go to Preferred Pharmacy then
um yeah this is also specific to health
maintenance organizations hmos not
necessarily all insurance carriers so it
is a little bit of a cound so rips and
richion what I have here is RSA 420 B12
okay but if I'm understanding
understanding what you're the point that
you're making um correctly and I may not
be keep in mind it's it the pharmacy is
still required to have a contract
somewhere right it's if they're not if
they don't have a contract for
reimbursement patient can't come in and
expect to get their pharmaceu their
prescription drug and have it covered
under the plan it understand so
basically if they want to they can sign
the contract with the insurance of the
PBM yeah so therefore the PV should be
willing to give them a
contract yeah well that sounds like wait
a minute I think the difference is if
there's going to be you know a certain
boilerplate contract if you're willing
to accept those terms then yes we can
contract with you but that does not mean
that that's the contractual rate because
they could be contracting with other
pharmacies and have different
reimbursement rates so I think there is
Nuance here and I think this just says
that you can that contract it does not
say it's not an any willing provider a
true any willing provider you don't need
to have that contract to be in network
or out of network it doesn't matter you
would just be able to go to whatever
Pharmacy you want and you would be able
to access that so some states do have
those any willing provider provisions
and that's not exactly what is here
please if I am an outof Network Pharmacy
and I want to have a contract with a PBM
Curtis don't go
away and I want to have a contract with
the
PBM would the PBM say your volume is so
low that I don't think this contract is
going to work out can they make
judgments as to whether or not they want
to make a contract with someone based on
various you know money things and
management things yeah generally
speaking it ensur is not required to
contract with any provider whether it's
Pharmacy or medical or a hospital it's
completely within the purview but you
have to meet Network adequacy
requirements you have to meet all of
these other things assuming you meet
those things then yes if you're um one
hold out and they had made their Network
adequacy requirements they do not need
you they do not have to contract with
you and there are no laws that require
you to contract necessarily with anyone
assuming you meet those requirements
certainly and I I think if I may um that
goes to the previous point and the rules
specifically the church department rules
on network adequacy uh
2701 um and specifically 07 um and
06 so they had there are different tiers
for different densities of population
the further the more rural you get the
the lower the requirement but if an if a
specific plan is having a difficulty
finding in this case a pharmacy to serve
the rural area they're going to be
forced to reimburse at a higher rate to
entice somebody to serve the population
right that's the way it works so that
that's where the different rates may
come in that make
sense can
I not
yet good try
though so what I'm trying to understand
is the role the insurance department has
over the PBM operations because if the
pharmacy or pharmacist wants to have a
complaint where do they go with it
where's the patient where do they go
with it at this point in time it sounds
like it's goes to no no man's land and
at that point in time if they're not
being held accountable operationally to
something to the
laws then what are we doing so consumers
pharmacies um providers they are all um
able to come to the department and file
complaint with our consumer services
even if it's a product we do not
regulate we do assist consumers in um
helping them navigate the system and
we'll tell them no this is not a product
we regulate this is who you will need to
reach out to again if it's in network
providers they should be working within
their um contract with their provider
reps to help figure out those issues
sometimes though that doesn't happen and
they do come to us and we will intervene
and help work out that situation for
them um so just to give you some stats
since January of 2023 so a little over a
year and a half
we've received approximately 68 consumer
complaints that in some way were related
to prescription drug um I'm I don't know
how many of those were necessarily
founded but that gives you an idea of
how many we get from consumers with
respect to um pharmacies in particular
we have rules and that's ins
274.00 6 is the complaint process for
pharmacies and we would um figure out if
is this something that we have
jurisdiction over is it something that
the Board of Pharmacy has Juris over
there is a mechanism for us to refer it
to them um under that process I I don't
think we've ever gotten a complaint but
I know for sure that we haven't had a
complaint since 2022 prior to that I'd
have to do a little bit more digging I
just didn't have the time to look up
that data but I was at the department
during that time and my recollection is
that we don't we've never gotten a
complaint from a pharmacy question yeah
one of the bills that we had that came
to us in the Commerce Committee was we
go uh regarded the the idea that there
is a board where a pharmacy can bring in
a complaint and say the Mac price is X
let's say but we can't get it for that
even though they have a contract I guess
but we can't get it for that
price where is the PBM what is their
obligation to tell the pharmacy where
they can get it for the price that the
pharmacy is s saying that the PBM is
saying with the insurance company yay
verily that's the price if you am I
making that clear yeah and I would have
to look that up because I I remember
reading but I don't exactly know where
that is in the rules and statute there
is the requirement though that they do
pay the usual customary rate or the
co-pay whichever is less so that is
meant to help protect pharmacies on that
but yes there is I believe a mechanism
and I'd have to look it up and I can get
that back to yeah the bill specific
specifically said that the pharmacy was
not given the information as to where
they could get that the drug for the
price you know so if we could find out
something about how that happens that
mechanism that would be good yes I will
look that up and get it back to you
thanks one last thing in regards to uh
prior approvals which is back to the
operational side of the
equation my understanding is there's a
certain
law that requires the patient to get a
certain amount of
medication prior to the prior approval
being processed if you
will so how many complaints have you had
with patients not being allowed to do
that look at this and saying 68 patients
over a year and give the number of
prescriptions that's that's H that's
minuscule yeah that's over a year and a
half and I mean I can't talk about
specifics but some of those could that
someone doesn't understand how they're
in network versus out of network or
preferred in network versus in network
Pharmacy work so they're questioning you
know the cost sharing or you know
they're questioning the accumulation of
something a lot of we do get a lot of um
complaints about
[Music]
um how the co- pays and um out of pocket
max is being accumulated and trying to
reconcile that with respect to being
able to access drugs again going off my
memory um I do review pretty much most
of these complaints but I don't recall
ever getting a complaint like that we do
have a law um 40 420j
7-b that does put in certain prior
authorization requirements that um I
think it's a 48 hour prior authorization
and
um yes there's the ability to get a
shortterm amount of the drug to hold
people over for certain things
so attorney heeden thank you for being
here but I do have a deep I mean deep
concern that over this period of time
the lack of complaints that have come
into the insurance
department and it probably goes back to
patients and the pharmacist not
understanding what their legal rights
are and where to go with it but this is
really not speaking highly of the
process so I don't know what the
insurance department can do to try to
inform patients inform providers of what
they can do to how they can file a
complaint because over 2022 from the
pracy world hearing zero is concerning
to me with 68 from patients is even more
concerning given the number of patients
that are out there it goes back to my
deep concern about the role the
insurance department has over the
operational aspect of a PBM and how
they're functioning within our state so
that they're abiding by the laws that's
what I'm trying to get to and thank you
for your testimony today I wanted to
turn it over to represent spere just on
that point though I mean we the
department does do a lot of Outreach but
yes this is a consistent thing that
we're trying to break through and make
sure that people understand not just for
prescription drugs but health insurance
generally they understand how Insurance
Works they understand their rights under
the product if they have any questions
to reach out to us that's what we're
here for to help those we do have a
whole Outreach division we have podcasts
we have uh we go to outreach events all
the time we try to do as much as we can
but you know there we's definitely
people we're still not reaching so we're
always trying to tell anyone if you have
any questions if you're unsure about how
your benefits are working if you think
there's a problem please reach out to
our consumer services because they can
help you navigate those
issues and all my time in the state of
New Hampshire I have not received those
so I thank you for all you trying but
I'm just one person one patient one Cen
that hasn't fallen on my desk yet so but
thank you for
trying my my last question is and don't
go
away getting back to this whole
relationship uh if I am a an insurance
carrier and I've hired CVS as a
PBM and that PBM also deals with do pbms
does CVS as a PBM ever deal with other
uh other pharmacies as a PBM would they
contract with another Pharmacy like R
Aid or something so I don't know about
CVS in specifically but yes pbms
generally would contract with several
yeah Network pharmacies if you have a
contract with a PBM any pharmacy has it
has a has a written contract with a PBM
is that PBM required in any way to let
those pharmacies
know where they can get the drugs you
know getting back to that other bill
that I was talking about where they can
get the drugs for the price that they've
agreed to with the insurance
company I don't know that I would think
that it should be in the contract but I
really don't know do you have an
answer on the Mac issue specifically I
think we're getting into that next then
Mr Hal is here I think he'll provide
some detailed information Ma
so thank you okay please reach out if
you have any additional questions like
my contacts in the um in there and I can
give you consumer services information
as well it's on our website thank you
and I will reach
out okay um I forgot to talk about the
minutes from the August 29th I want to
thank the clerk represent Cole for being
so kind to be the clerk last meeting and
to have you folks look at the minutes
and if we could have a motion on the
floor to accept the minutes
and second
please I'll second it
sure is there any discussion on the
minutes that
fine all those in favor say I all those
opposed abstain the eyes have it
now moving on to the next topic for
today is the world of
mac and maximum allowable
cost and pharmacist Clifford if you
would be so kind as to step forward and
talk about how the state deals or
develops a Mac list and so forth I'll
try to be kind to you as well um so if
you could help us understand the Mac
world what does it mean how does it get
developed what the process is how does
the State Medicaid the if a service
utilizes the Mac list it' be helpful to
the committee to begin to understand the
process if you don't mind thank you okay
so I may have misunderstood your
question um that you sent ahead of time
so I thought the question had to do with
the uh Mac list being available publicly
and I'm prepared to speak to that I know
there are federal requirements on how a
Mac gets calculated and and I know um
that there there have to be a certain
number of generic equivalents Pro
available so a Mac is only used on
generic drugs and there has to be a set
number of generics available so like for
example when a drug first goes generic
there's a six-month exclusivity period
given to the first generic available so
during that first six-month period you
can't have a Mac price on on that drug
drug because there's not enough choices
available to order I can get you those
specific details on the calculation I
just don't have them today um but you
had asked if our Mac list was publicly
available and currently our Mac list is
available to providers that sign up to
view it in the provider portal um but I
did talk with our Pharmacy benefit
administrator and they do have some
State Medicaid programs that they work
with that are publishing their Mac on a
public fa facing website so I put in a
request to move the New Hampshire Mac to
the public facing website and that's
being worked on I can tell you the the
frequency though um all of the drugs are
reviewed
weekly and there could possibly be
weekly updates um and we so we have uh
we l published file that will be um
added to the public facing website and
we have a monthly file that will be put
on the public facing website and when we
move it to the public facing website we
will also put in our our Mac um review
request so when a
pharmacy contacts myself um and says
that they can't purchase the drug for
that that price then we send them out
the Mac challenge form and that gets um
that that Mac price reviewed quickly for
that
Pharmacy um so it you know if it falls
outside the regular um sometimes it's
just a matter of the the drug price
updated and we haven't done our weekly
file update yet so because we only our
drug prices are updated weekly most phes
get price updates
daily so um but we do have a challenge
form and those are reviewed and if it
needs to be adjusted it gets
adjusted but Mac isn't the
only price that Medicaid uses so we use
a lesser of pricing logic so Medicaid
reimburses at the lesser of the NC which
is National Drug acquisition cost if
there's no NC available for that drug we
use the whack which is the wholesale
acquisition cost um but if there's a Mac
and the Mac is less it it pays at the
Mac if the pharmacy's usual and
customary charge is less then we pay at
the pharmacy's usual and customary
charge but getting back to my other
question yes you have the data but do
pharmacies know where they can get the
drug drug for that
price I don't know that we know where
they can get the drug for that price we
we have a contract with a um a drug
pricing
compendium and that's where the prices
for the Mac come so when a pharmacy
challenges the Mac price and they submit
their invoice as part of that challenge
that can be recalculated for the
pharmacy
yeah well thank you for um Farm Clipper
for that information in regards to
the
file because one of the things I wanted
to talk to uh Mr Curtis later on or
somebody is that I've been told to have
some documentation here
that there was a drug over the course of
a year had 177 price points
so what I'm trying to understand from
New Hampshire Medicaid when you have a
price point on the Mac of the list if
you will is that consistent across all
pharmacies or is that depending upon
some sort of relationship you have with
the pharmacy Pharmacy a guess One Price
Pharmacy b gets another Price Pharmacy C
gets another price I mean is it really
consistent for New Hampshire Medicaid it
is the Mac price is the price and that
price would be paid to all pharmacies
depending on how that claim
you know like I said we use a lesser of
logic so if the pharmacy's usual in
customary charge comes in lower that
Pharmacy would get their usual customary
charge now another Pharmacy might have a
higher usual and customary charge and
their claim May pay at a Mac or whack or
naak but the price the price in the file
is consistent yes across all pharmacies
yes okay that's very helpful thank you
and there's a weekly file and a monthly
file what distinguish between the weekly
and the
monthly uh it goes on price updates from
the drug compendia so if a drug had a a
change in their price that was listed
from the previous week and we need to
increase that price it would increase
sooner than rather rather than waiting
for the monthly file to update so if the
price goes down does it also go down yes
so so it's really the monthly file is
there provided there's no real changes
in the marketplace
his they is pretty stagnant for that
month and versus they weekly depending
upon Market
volatility correct
okay and how many challenges has the
state of New Hampshire
had I'm aware of one in the last year
one but that's for the fee for service
population and the fee for service
population is relatively small
you know if if there's a challenge with
somebody who's in a Medicaid managed
care that would go to the Medicaid
Managed Care
Organization okay thank you
y any other questions for Pharm
clippard thank
you the other one I wanted in your
packet here I Shar this with um Mr
Curtis is looking at Mac prices
according to what I have here from a
couple of
sources the price points for Mac are all
over the
board and I'm trying to understand why
you would have the same
drug on the same
day in the same Pharmacy with three
different price points I just don't
understand that and number two is if I'm
the pharmacist trying to ensure that I'm
above water on the Mac list so when I go
to my wholesaler Mr Barry I can sit
there and say to Mr wholesaler what
you're charging me is not sustainable
because I'm being told by my insurance
or my PBM that there's a price out there
at this price point that I should be
able to buy it at so where is it and why
can't I do that but it sounds like the
pharmacy doesn't really have visibility
and transparency in what those price
points are so when I'm buying the
product I'm sort of behind the aball you
want to step forward and take the
mic sure just state your name
please good afternoon my name is Sam Hol
with pcma which is National trade
Association for pharmacy benefit
managers uh so Mr chairman I'll take a
stab at your first question on the
various price points and Mac lists so
pbns do have various Mac lists depending
on the type of client and contract of
the pharmacy so say it's a a carrier or
a client that has um not as many lives
they might not get as a a higher
reimbursement at the pharmacy so there's
one Mac list but say it's a carrier with
a lot of lives they will and it brings
more foot traffic to a pharmacy that
will have a different Mac list so there
are various reasons why there are
various Mac lists and I can follow this
up with all of you um but from our
perspective a pharmacy can a pharmacist
can look at a live Mac price through
various PBM
portals so they can go to the portal my
question then is how
long is that price held for is it held
for a month 24 hours a week typically
mless change frequently uh it depends on
the PBM in the current market situation
there could be drug shortages there
could be supply chain issues but it does
change pretty frequently yes typically
it's seven
days typically yes so it could be less
than weekly in some instances yes it can
okay is there any
I'm I'm just trying to put myself in the
shoes of the pharmacist trying to be
sure that what I'm trying to buy from
the wholesaler I've been told that the
wholesaler is major problem here but I'm
trying to understand with the wholesaler
if I don't know what my reimbursement
price is I can't hold my wholesaler
accountable so how do you help the
pharmacist understand what their price
point is so they can actually go to the
wholesaler and put leverage on the
wholesaler sure again pbms have portals
that they can access these Mac list
prices Live and then as far as the
relationship between a pharmacy and a
wholesaler pbms don't have insight to
that but if I understand it correctly it
can change daily change so therefore if
I go on to it look on Tuesday my comes
in on Thursday I don't know if I'm going
to be above or below the water because
the price point on Thursday will be
different than the price point on
Tuesday when I went to look for my order
into the wholesaler I I understand I
hear you and I hear that frustration but
yeah that is what we use to make sure
that pharmacies purchase drugs at um an
affordable price to keep prices low for
PBM clients I totally understand that
but there's needs to be some give and
take here between the pvm world and the
Mac world and also the wholesaler I've
got a pharmacist in the middle between
the two sure and I'm trying to figure
out how to help them run a business
absolutely and my recommendation would
be the psos and wholesalers need to be
brought into this discussion is there a
whole another entity within the Pharmacy
space that's not in this room that I'm
aware of okay if I bring them in which
is fine they're going to tell me well I
don't know what the reimbursement is for
the pharmacist so how am I going to know
at this point in time if they're above
or below water I don't know how does the
wholesaler know your price points they
do so wholesalers also run something
called PSA Pharmacy Services
administrative organizations they
contract with independentes think of it
like uh a group of pharmacies to uh
increase their purchasing power those P
so a group ofes will be under a psao
that psao contracts with the PBM on
reimbursement rates yeah that same psao
also is a wholesaler selling those
pharmacies drugs at various price
points so my response back to you would
be a pharmacist could reach out to a
wholesaler and they would know they they
may or may not know they W know I hear
was saying I I lived in the space for
the last 40 years a pharmacy service
administrative organization which is
psao negotiates a contract they don't
know what the PBM Mac is going to be
they don't negotiate the Mac all they do
is negotiate the price with the PBM and
I can tell you from my own experience
and living in that
space let me understand the difference
between the price and the Mac in your
sit in what you just described if I go
to my
wholesaler and I want to buy a generic
drug aspirin
and I'm looking at the cost from the
wholesaler and it's going to cost me $10
for a bottle of 100 which comes out to
10 cents per tablet okay that's my
cost I want to go to the wholesaler
ensure that at this point in time I can
buy it for at least 8 cents or even 10
to break even and I don't know where the
pharmacist is going to get the
information to be sure that from a
business point of view they're staying
home
and that's what I'm trying to get to
psao does not have they have the
wholesal information I don't disagree
that's true what they don't have is the
Mac information coming from the PBM
that's off the
table my response back would be the
pharmacists can or the pharmacy can take
a look at the Mac list and price at that
time and work with their
wholesaler and I I can't speak to the
relationship between a pharmacy and a
wholesaler no but you can speak to the
relationship between the pharmacy and
the PBM right and I just heard that we
could hold a price point for at least a
week maybe even two weeks that way there
they know during that period of time
they can high movers they can buy the
product at a price point that's been
locked in for a two we period of time
maybe 30 days it's going to be some
point in time that they have some
Assurance to what that price point is
and if I heard it correctly on the price
point the price Point's all over to
place anyways because it depends upon
whe it's a big employer small emplo
employer I don't even know at this point
in time what my Mac price is going to be
even if you go into the portal does a
portal tell me a large wholesaler I mean
a large plan versus a small plan does it
differentiate that way they can see they
can view the Mac list for those pbms yes
for all the plans correct so every
single plan they can go in and see the
Mac price I'll follow up to confirm but
that's my understanding yes okay because
what I heard was in your statement that
a large employer may get a different
price point correct and a small employer
gets a different price point so there's
various Mac lists that they can view
within the PBM yes and they will know
would you get back to me on that please
absolutely because I'm looking at this
and saying is that I'm just trying to
level the playing field to be sure at
this point in time whatever the Mac is
going to be and I'm looking at I think
representative um Cole I won't speak on
your behalf but I think part of it is if
it can be locked in for a period of time
so the person knows what it is and why
we have
eight different Mac portals I mean if
I'm thinking operationally get back into
it if I'm in the pharmacy and place it
an order M and I have to go to a portal
and look at eight and I would say the
plans could be more than eight could be
all over the place I have to determine
which one of those plans is the one I'm
going to use as my average because I
don't know what my food traffic is going
to be that's what I'm trying to get to
is how do we ensure that the pharmacist
has some visibility into a Mac price
that's locked in for a period of time
and that they that point in time can
rely upon it and not have something
exchange such volatility it's changing
on a daily basis maybe even by the hour
that's what I'm trying to understand I
understand because I'm looking at this
here and studies I've seen is they're
all over the place which is which just
said to me there are there's many Macs
many different lists and so forth
it's so complicated so difficult I don't
know how anyone can make any any logic
out of it I I understand chair Mr
chairman but from the PBM perspective
you know we contract with pharmacies on
quality and on price to make sure that
our clients can get drugs safely but
also at an affordable price as well I
understand the frustration on the
pharmacy side as well but again I we're
only talking about one side of the
equation between the PBM and the
pharmacy I still think with that we need
to bring in that other side between the
pharmacy and the wholesaler psao as well
if you can help me understand this side
and I can understand it well enough i'
be more than glad to bring in the other
side but right now I'm still not quite
sure I understand this side before I
bring him the other side and number two
if you could help me as well when was
the last
time either Express Scripts
Kart aam RX with a pharmacy actually
changed any language in their contract
being the trade representative I don't
have any individual contracts because
what I've been told it's a take it or
leave it that they don't negotiate they
basically say you can either do business
with us or not do business with us
that's not
negotiations so I would like to find out
from the trade
Association how often and how willing
are they to change their contract or is
it one size fits all and that's it
because that's so important because you
keep going back to the contract keep
going back to the contract and you keep
talking about it being negotiated well
negotiating means the two parties sit
down and negotiate something if it comes
down to here's the
contract you can sign it take it or
leave it if you want to do business with
us there's a piece of paper and sign it
if you don't want to that's okay too I'd
like to understand how much flexibility
do we have within the PBM world with the
Contracting CU that goes back to the
basis of the Mac price sure cuz I'm sure
it's built into the contract we know
before working in the industry there was
gag clauses I couldn't even tell the
patient that they paid
cash it would be less expensive for them
because there was contract language that
prohibit prohibited me from doing that
that's gone thank
goodness so I'm trying to
understand what's going on with the
mac's going on the contracts he keeps
saying they're negotiated if I can
understand this I'll be more than glad
to have the wholeale come in understood
okay Gary yeah thank you based on the
bills that we saw in Commerce that's
only one part of it the problems that we
would that we were hearing about is okay
fine you've established a price where
can I get it for that price so it's not
just how often it's also okay fine where
can I get
it oh please
please stand please come to the mic so
we thank you please state your name hi
yes Margaret Reynolds with siga and
Express Scripts uh happy to be
here I'll start with Mac but I have a
couple of notes I took from the previous
presentation I'm happy to answer
questions on as well um I am not as
familiar with how of the lists or
varying lists we might have I will work
with Sam we will get you that
information um in other states as far as
Mac goes there are laws that say it must
be updated at least every seven days
that's our general practice but
certainly if a state says it must be
updated every five days we can do that
it's tighter but seven is our general
practice how me St I heard at least
every seven days correct correct do say
a minimum of seven days correct so
therefore if it's at least 7even days it
could change
daily no at least every seven days so it
could be longer so it needs to be within
seven
days am I saying that
right I don't think
so I not the way the way I'm
interpreting this is that if this is at
least every seven days that means
correct but if you're doing it
daily that's still within seven days yes
I will say seven days is our general
practice that is what we do if it was
less than seven our team would say
that's a very tight turnaround so seven
is our general practice but as a state
if you were to say should not be updated
within seven days we would wait for the
sday window or longer cor so we basic
want to try to think it through is that
we freeze it for a week that's all or
two or four
but I'm trying to get to there's a time
that the list is Frozen that's all okay
right now it's really not it's at least
every seven days which means it will
turn over every seven days but it can
turn over before
that we could come to an agreement on
that because I'm saying seven days is
our general practice but general
practice does not mean that that's okay
than not everywhere all the time correct
um and then as far as contracts go that
goes back to the Network aacy adequacy
conversation that was from earlier if
there's a pharmacy and there's not
another one within 20 miles and they're
the only game in town we certainly want
to negotiate with them to have them in
our
network but back to the psao
conversation if they are part of a
larger psao with 30 other pharmacies we
are now negotiating with that
psao that affects all of the pharmacy so
that becomes harder to do independent
terms with an independent Pharmacy
because we're no longer talking to them
directly we're talking to a psao which
represents more
pharmacies um but no I mean we certainly
negotiate uh it just depends on the
network and ensuring that we meet those
Network adequacy
requirements would you do some homework
for us sure I'd like to find out in
State of New Hampshire how many
contracts you've actually negotiated
sure you mean truly negotiated not
something it's a take or leave
it I can contact our Contracting team I
am not the person with that information
but I like
homework um and then the only I
shouldn't say only because I'm sure I'll
have plenty to say but and when you ask
the question about the contracts and
negotiating the contracts it' be helpful
to understand what parts of the contract
are you negotiating sure is it not the
beginning date and end
date okay thank
you yes um and then one other point I
wanted to call out from the previous
presentation you were asking about a
portal for consumers to know what the
price is um and I don't represent good
RX but good RX does exist it's a website
you would put in the zip code and what
your script is the problem with good RX
is it is not reflective of what you
would pay under your benefit it is
reflective of what you would pay as a
cash price or if you're uninsured or
underinsured um so it there is a portal
out there that exists um but it would
not tell you what your benefit is as a
sigma Express SCP Express Scripts
customer I can go to our insurance
website I can put in my drug that I'm
looking for and it will tell me what's
in my network and what my outof pocket
is but that's because that's catered to
my benefit so it wouldn't be for
everyone else to see what my price is
but I know what my copay is does that it
it helps actually I've used the portal
myself a couple of times so I understand
it completely okay um one of the things
that I would say about good RX is there
any cost of the pharmacy to use good ARX
not that I'm aware of I I'm I'm
hopefully there's pharmacists that can
answer if they have to pay a fee to
access that but I know it's free to
consumers to just go on there and price
shop for the cash price well maybe we
have one of the pharmacists that are
here
no um you want to get off the hot seat
don't blame you either um do you want to
finish your comments before I have them
come up and
speak I'm happy to answer any if there's
any other questions regarding Mac I'm I
mean I'm not an expert in Mac but I love
homework so happy to take questions
back is it possible for PBM is set the
rates for a b we period and be done with
it for how long sorry two weeks for two
weeks what kind of pressure would that
put on
pbms I mean it's not our standard I
guess the counter to that is if the
price were to increase the reimbursement
were to increase on a drug then the
pharmacy would still be under for those
two weeks because it's not reflective of
the market dynamics right so we try to
update it so that every one knows and is
on a field but I I the points were made
earlier about being able to negotiate
and ensuring that they're getting that
price so point
taken thank you Mr chairman something I
mentioned at the last meeting but I have
to mention it again because I've been
around a while um and I don't mean to be
flipped but there's a statute on the
books that on this specific subject that
says the PBM shall review and make
necessary adjustments to the maximum
allowable cost for every drug for which
the price has changed at least every 14
days and I'm smiling because it was the
New Hampshire Independent Pharmacy
Association that said we're they're
changing it um not often enough it
doesn't change in the price of our
acquisition changes and they're not
changing the Mac price so that was not
that long ago that they said we're not
changing it often enough and now we're
changing it too
often I'm struggling this I I think The
Sweet Spot would be rep and Cole sounds
like two weeks is a sweet spot because
that's what we agree to is they have to
do it every two weeks so if we just
freeze it for two weeks and everybody's
happy I can't speak for individual pbms
but I hope you understand and appreciate
the point that I'm making I hear the
point do you hear the my point as well
it was it was their Association that
came in and said we're not changing it
often I mean right and just because the
Mac price is Frozen for two weeks
doesn't mean you can buy it for
that absolutely SP so you got to have to
find out the b the problems we were
seeing in Commerce was yeah fine we've
got a Mac price here but I can't find
any place I can buy it for that because
you got a wholesaler on the other side
then that's going to be the
next audience to bring in and talk about
why the pharmacy can't find it at that
price makes sense um for
context I think it's at least indirectly
related to the con contract discussion
um between the last meeting in this one
I took a look at the pharmacy the retail
pharmacy licenses in the state of New
Hampshire um at the time I looked it up
there were 271 Retail Pharmacy locations
in the state of New Hampshire 199 of
those were chains so CVS right a
Walgreens includes hanford's includes
Walmart includes Target
199 uh 42 seem to be hospitals Health
Center institutions um nine were some
other maybe compound infusion um one
mail order which I think is pill pack um
and roughly 20
Independents so it 271 for a state of
1.3 million
people and my concern is going to be a
lot of times the independence because of
the ones that probably don't have a lot
of the muscle that the larger chains
have I'm not I'll be sure everyone's
treated equally I'm not going to focus
my attention stly one part of the market
but I'm looking at them specifically
because they're the ones that seem to be
having more of the issue than some of
the other ones and I can share and
you've seen it now right a just get out
of
bankruptcy sure so what I'm saying this
Market was working so so
dramatically okay I don't I don't know
yet of a PM that's fed for
bankruptcy but we could find one I'm
sure and I think we could agree that
right a is more than just a pharmacy
they're also a convenience store and I'm
I haven't seen any evidence that it's
Pharmacy reimbursement that drove it
into bankruptcy versus just maybe not
great business decisions we that would
take a different
analysis understood but I also can look
at the other ones on the other side of
the fence with Walgreens announcing 10%
closure CVS is looking closure and so
forth and I'm sure if the business model
was there and the pharmacy were vibrant
they wouldn't be closing them and I
think you can look at every other type
of retail business because I used to
represent the industry whether it's Home
Depot and Lowe's uh Best Buy Any kind of
retailer they add locations they take
away locations it's the nature of
business based upon their market
performance which I totally understand
but my other concern is going to be the
patients sure because when we create
Pharmacy deserts and we have Pharmacy
deserts then we have bigger issues going
on with patient access and and the
statutes and the rules in the insurance
department for Network adequacy address
that issue directly they those rules
were reopt again not that long ago pre-
pandemic but in my you know my recent
memory and as far as the contracts with
The Independents go I would be
interested to know from The Independents
if they're represented by a psao or not
I think that's an important piece of
information maybe we should invite the
PS psao in and find out how successful
they are in negotiating with the big
three I think you should invite the PSA
in so thank you thank you as is there
somebody from the pharmacy Community
wants to get up and talk about Mac
or
anything concerns you folks have at this
point in time I
mean yeah
it could you help us with the insurance
department two parts of it we had two
presentations one was the insurance
department talking about their
oversight
regulatory of pbms and I want to
understand from your point of view
what's your interpretation that what
does it mean and the other side is going
to be on the Mac
side why you can't find the drugs on the
market represent a spirit's point of
view at the point above the Mac or at
least at the Mac so you're at least at
that point in time keeping yourself
hold okay we can my my name is Steve
cavadas um I'm an independent Pharmacy
owner uh on the Contracting side
what I I think the question is is how
much control do we have with that
absolutely none uh the only control that
we have is opt in or opt out um when we
talk about
negotiating that that is
non-existent um now we do use a
psao um and the thought process that
it's only 30 stores no it's a it's
thousands of stores so when we look at
how do we compare you know the Mac price
of the the size of the entity well we're
as big as the chains so Nationwide which
is how these contracts work uh at least
to my knowledge so there's a little bit
of bickering that goes back and forth
between the psao and the PBM um but I
don't think that it is a a adequate
contractual relationship where both
parties
benefit we're always in a situation
where this is what it is and if you
don't want it leave it um if I
could so is the contract with yourself
in the psao OR with the directly with
the PBM we have both we have a contract
with the PC psao that that does the
majority of the contracts and then we
have independent contracts with those
that do not play in the sandbox with the
psao do you know what they are at the
top of your head human man is one that I
have and I I believe we have a separate
contract with KARK as
well if you could find out yep be
helpful is with the
PSO which pvms are covered by that and
which ones you're doing independently
the ones you're doing independently
again it' be helpful understand are you
actually negotiating that independent
contract or you basically this is a take
to leave it it's usually it's facts to
us that says opt in or opt out thank
you I was an independent Pharmacy oh I'm
sorry my name is Glenn peral Colonial
Pharmacy New London um I have contracted
independently with um pbms and gone
through psao I've used psao affiliated
with
wholesalers I've also used a psao who is
an independent psao align
RX um the
um the Contracting is is is the same no
matter which way the I've tried red
lining on my own uh I know the psos have
tried red lining uh and try to
renegotiate the contract and they're
they're is no movement on rate the only
movement that we see uh is on
reporting
um there's some effective rate language
that in there uh that may move a little
bit but basically the reimbursement rate
does not
move um and so the
um you talk about um patient steering L
willing
provider uh the big problem with with
with those types of Law and what we've
seen recently with the um DOD Tri care
contract was
if a PBM does not want you in
network then they offers a
ridiculous reimbursement rate and they
won't have you in in their Network and
that's one of the big things that that
uh I know Congress is discussing right
now is is the latest DOD Tri care um
contract ises that contract through a
PBM or is that contract with federal
government it's through a PBM uh
prescripts
um is the PBM involved with the dod Tri
care what reason would they give for not
wanting you in the
network I I don't
know I was under the impression that the
dod wanted to have less
vendors okay without really thinking
about the unintended consequence of that
decision so you know I think it was just
a
downhill we need less vendors um but but
but I don't have anything to back that
up that was just
something indries I've read and and what
not didn't make sense to me uh if if you
paying the same rate to to everybody and
that's my interpretation of the any
willing you know provider then what
difference doesn't make how many vendors
you have if you're paying them the same
and I think that that's there's a a huge
misunderstanding about the any willing
provider
because when we look at the chains
versus ourselves and versus mail order
if everybody's being reimbursed the same
amount then I don't think that mail
order would be
cheaper now you're adding the expense of
mail and all that Garb I I don't want to
sound Flip or anything like that but
I've seen them do it with military
aircrafts so I know they do this doesn't
make any difference what the business is
they want as few contractors as possible
and it it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense in many cases so I appreciate what
you're
saying now to comment on the Mac
discussion about the time frame I I am
going to agree with the this gentleman
over here um
that the prices do go up rapidly on
certain drugs and right now the entire
add Market is on its ear as far as
pricing so sort of locking us into a
price that's two weeks old uh it would
be tough because in some cases like on
generic viance it has gone from $300
bottle to $1,200 a bottle so you know we
would have to say for two weeks well
we're not going to serve you we're not
going to serve you you know the problem
is with the Mac is that you I was one of
the people that tried to get it to
understand where they're getting a
product from is that we are
contractually obligated to keep the
majority of our purchases with our
primary
wholesaler so you know in order to get
best price and once again our buying
group is thousands of stores not just
one or two or 30 um you know we it it's
hard to find better
pricing um
so I'd leave the timing available you
know so that these things can fluctuate
the problem is is that they they go down
faster than they go up is issue number
one from from our perspective and and
and and that's just anecdotal you know
you see the the pricing you see the
losses you go oh my gosh that was quick
that that you know they changed it to go
down but they don't change it to go up
he's talking about the max right the max
max change down very very quickly but
they're very very slow to go up
it's just talking to Cole it sounded
like the um way the gasoline prices work
they go up real quick they come down
rolls low correct correct and that was
the whole the you know in in last uh
meeting that we were here yes there are
rules on we can uh uh audit the Mac
price and ask for the a review and
whatnot uh but that is an exercise that
is is just futile uh I've done hundreds
of
of of requests myself outside of the
psao and I would say maybe mid to Upper
90 percentile are denied so so what role
does the insurance department do to help
you that is that is one of our issues
that we tried to bring up is that we
have no place to go to and once again
based on what I've he is that well it's
a Mac list and they're paying the Mac
list and and contractually they have a
Mac list so all the laws are being
followed
it's just
that there's some ethical issues here
and you know to be able to say in and
the reasoning that they were not able to
tell us where to buy that product was
because it would be an undue burden on
them now they're taking thousands of Mac
requests probably daily throughout the
Country Weekly at least and they're
denying these they have people that are
looking at the prices they're figuring
out what they should be they spend time
to have different Mac prices on all
these different list of all these
different entities but they can't tell
me where it comes from
so it it always seems to everything
benefits them and at the end of the day
we're all stakeholders in this process
and how can we all be in the and in the
sandbox together to to provide care when
there's just so much non-transparency
and no answers and that is the
frustration that we have at least I have
um so you know the whole Mac thing is a
joke um you know so basically there is a
contract price and if oh if we are if if
the pharmacy is benefiting off of that
contract price we are going to move it
to a Mac list there's no Rhyme or Reason
in my mind I don't know and they can
tell me that what's the logic of making
it non Mac to
Mac um
and so if I could ask a simple question
of the pain points that are out there
which one seems to be the most
problematic is it the question of Mac is
it a question I mean at this point in
time you what you negotiate on your
dispensing fees to negotiate between you
and the PBM and that's a business
decision but what I'm trying to get to
is the transparency about Mac so that
everyone's on the same page in some way
that you
can rest assured that you're able to
acquire it then the question will be
where do you go if I heard it correctly
too if you do file an call it a
complaint or Challenge on the Mac
challenge is if you don't get a
response you don't have anywhere to go
right so that's where looking at the
insurance department insurance is going
to say what's in the contract well okay
yes so there's no arbitrator the
insurance department should be acting as
an arbitrator somehow begin to listen to
both sides I think it's a role that they
could play and it goes back to the
operations we go back to before is that
how do you it's not just you I'm looking
at the patient side of the equation too
with prior approvals because when you go
through a prior approval process
providers and Physicians and patients
you get caught into this process and
it's very complicated in some ways very
convoluted but I'm not sure what people
have where they can go and and then
there's silly unintended consequences of
that so as an example you know you as an
example you get a a script in that
requires a prior authorization you give
them a three-day Supply happens to be a
controlled C2 uh script now it's dead so
now the patient has a three-day Supply
but we can't we can't rebuild the rest
to the insurance company then we have
get the provider involved and and it's
just a a massive waste of time um and
and and the frustrating thing about the
prior authorizations is that there are
some not many but there are some where
we it takes forever to get this approval
and then it comes back that the patient
pays
100%
co-pay and I lose so we have this huge
entity that is controlling absolutely
Ely everything and it benefited nobody
now yes we can argue oh yes we got the
drug drug cheaper for the for the
client well yeah but this is why we have
deserts and this is why we're closing
and this is why we're not carrying the
products anymore and this is why people
are finding it more and more difficult
to find their
stuff you know we have to
survive and we're just asking for people
to be fair and transparency is a huge
begin
huge part of this that everybody hides
ping you know curtains and we get
nowhere with it and as soon as it's too
much work for the PBM then it it falls
out of committee so could you help me in
a very broad sense what percentage of
the business and the prescription is not
the front end but the business of
filling prescription what percentage of
your business today is going through a
pvm versus the old days most of it was
cash so what's happening now because it
was probably 80 90% cash back in the 80s
is what percentage of your business now
going through pbms I would I would guess
and and this isn't I I could pull some
numbers for you but I would be surprised
if it was greater than
10% cash cash cash so B basically 90% of
it's going through a PBM process
absolutely and and it's probably higher
than that question
yes please uh you you spoke of uh in
generalities of problems and of course
we can't attack generalities but can you
give us some examples and maybe you did
in some of these emails that we just got
today of EX of the specific types of
incidences and problems that you're
having that we could try to
address I mean just saying that the
insurance companies a black hole doesn't
help correct that so part of it is
consistent pricing so so
although as Peg was saying earlier
Medicaid has their their reimbursement
which is very generous compared to
everybody else but since most of
Medicaid goes through the mcos well that
doesn't count and they were able to
carve out the pricing of that when they
when they develop those contracts so
although Medicaid has a Mac list and
Medicaid has a reimbursement structure
and Medicaid thinks that our dispensing
fee should be whatever they have it as
nobody else follows that and and they
don't have to and the dispensing fees
that they give us are in the
pennies um so it it's almost worthless
to have that as part of the contract you
know when we look at the National Data
it actually costs between what 1050 11
something per script um and and and and
we really are you know having to squeeze
that 10% of our customers to help make
up the tunnel losses and and once again
you know I'm not saying that the PBM
should not make money you know and
they're in their contracts they're
allowed to make
20% and we discussed that last time and
and we can talk about what all that
means but that is not allowed in my
business okay that for them for the PBM
sorry if I'm pointing in this direction
but if if the PBM said to me I want to
make sure you make
20% I would send them flowers for our
benefit because some of us are older
than others of us could you write this
down and and provide it to us so we
don't forget and we can address the
issue yeah we can we can distri problem
I've seen that but I have not heard so
far that that is that kind of an issue
and I'd like to get some more clarity on
that yeah representative Merchant
mentioned um Mac Plus dispensing fee and
the dispensing fee is
contractual just so that the committee
is aware there are no dispensing fees
we're not talking dollars anymore we're
talking nickels and dimes as a as a
dispensing fee when we transmit a claim
off to uh get adjudicated our
transmission fees are higher than the
dispensing
fees generally speaking and I gave you
some examples of those are actual ual
patient profiles from my Pharmacy and
you can see the impact and the
reimbursement that I'm getting for those
prescriptions they do not cover the vial
the cap and the label never mind any
other label any other labor that went
into it that's what we're dealing with
and you have a patient that's getting
nine prescriptions that's a critical
patient and out of those nine
prescriptions you have one brand name
medication and the brand name
reimbursement we're losing 3040 $50 on
and and you're done you you're you're
done you you make eight or n9ine dollars
on the other eight prescriptions and you
lose 50 on the one brand name I think I
provided my August dispensings of brand
name medications and you can see how far
underwater I was on brand name
dispensing is that the document you gave
us just today correct okay that is
grossly under represented of what I used
to do because I am telling patients I
can't fill their prescriptions anymore
they're going off to other stores um if
they're getting them at all because I
don't know who in their right mind would
would take on these these patients that
we're losing hundreds thousands of
dollars a year on that's one month
that's per month that yeah that's that's
one month that of that that print out
that I gave you um to answer another
Representatives questions
do the good RX single care cards require
a fee I provided a document of another
trick that the pbms are doing now if
their pricing is higher than those
discount
cards without any knowledge to the
patient before it was out without any
knowledge to the pharmacy but we have
ways of detecting it now fortunately
they would transfer it over to a a
discount card and the discount card
would take their fee and you can see the
examples that I've laid out um there are
some substantial nearly
$1,400 claims that were transferred to a
discount
card patients pays the drug up pays the
price at the
register and that amount because it was
transferred to a discount card does not
apply to their out of-pocket deductible
so if they go to another Pharmacy they
may not realize that but I have a
conversation with them at the counter
and let them know what's
happening yeah and that's and that's how
I know there's a anti- clawback bill
that's how they get around
it the the amount of minutia that you
have to write into your laws is
unbelievable why do you care
if they're you if
the pharmacy is using uh or if somebody
finds a discount card that maybe they
got from a drug drug dealer I mean a
drug
supplier drug dealer why do you care if
they're using that because don't you get
you you still get the uh the price for
the you can see the clawback that's
happening you on the document that I
printed you okay I'll wait and read it
okay let's make a clarification there's
a difference between a discount card
from a
manufacturer and a discount card like
good RX now years ago when good RX came
out you know I had somebody come in I
like sure we'll take it and I ran the
claim and my price was cheaper than the
good RX price so they gave them my price
and then they charged me
$16 now I didn't make $16 on the scrip
and a lot of times the fees that are
going back through to the
discount cards through the PBM
maneuver the the discount card makes
more than I do and I'm losing money you
know so where's the logic in all this
where you you know this is just crazy
and and I would
be their solvency is not a problem um
it's just a money machine and
unfortunately we have zero protection I
have tried looking at the insurance
department to see where can I go with
this and if we're just looking at the
laws well they're following the laws but
they're
also finding ways to to make that
advantage to them so the pbms supply
these good RX
cards I'm not sure if they Supply them I
would venture they're involved somehow
but we're not saying what that is yet I
mean we don't know what that is yet it
happens in the back ground so I transmit
off a claim I think it's I think it's
going off to CVS KARK I think it's going
off to KARK they have a KARK card uh it
comes back to me
adjudicated and the way I see it is and
you'll see my print screens that I
provided they'll say patient pays in my
example I think it was n
$916 it says third party remit
$658 but we don't know who that the
third party is that's the discount
so on that one screen you don't see it
but I also printed out the EDI data
received and you will see that it shows
the bin number and then it says GDX next
to the bin number which means they
transferred it off to the good RX card
yeah well Staker that that's alls to me
allow us to a little research thank you
Mr Curtis um it's 3:30 I want to try to
be sensitive to people's time I want to
say thank you for being here it would
ask you if you have a
contact with a psao or SL wholesaler
that we can possibly contact I'm trying
to find out if we can actually have
somebody give a presentation remotely so
they don't have to be here physically um
but I'm still working my way through
that process
but if You' email it to me and so forth
if I can reach out to them I think
that's important I have some homework
coming from the insurance department
from attorney Heaton um as far as that
goes I think Mr Barry you've got a
couple of to-dos I think CVS um Express
SCP sorry has a couple of to-dos
um did I miss anybody I've got them down
here somewhere I'm sure you probably
have all you too but I want to say at
this point in time the next meeting will
be on October 3rd at 1:30 location I'm
not sure I think Miss Davis is working
on that the meeting after that will be
October 17th again at 1:30 and if
necessary wrap this up will be October
26 we need to get some sort of report
out recommendation if you will from this
committee about future legislation and
maybe at that point in time one of those
meetings with my colleagues on this
committee is talk about drafting some
potential legislation at least focus on
a couple of topics I think Max is
probably a big one and the other one's
going to going be the role of the
insurance department within the PBM
World itself I think what I heard was
what are we doing operationally as far
as plan design and things of that nature
it's Aisa um that's really up to the
plan it's up to the employer it's up to
people buying it I don't think this
committee should be involved with the
plan design but when you're dealing with
the nuts and bolts of the operation and
communication and accountability and Mac
challenges and all those things I think
that's something that's right for a
discussion so I want toour the meeting
at 3:30 and I want to say thank you